et c'est vrai que on dit que vous avez
été victime d'un acharnement au sein des
anges
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour les
trois qui veut des margelles ça veut
dire quoi
un acharnement oui alors en fait ce sont
tout simplement 15 personnes qui vont se
mettre sur une seule candidate et qui
vont la pousser
psychologiquement à bout et ça c'est
vraiment à travers à travers des
humiliations des insultes moi dans mon
cas on m'a balancé du ont aspergé le
visage de produits ménagers
on m'a insulté de supplément au terme de
plus de [ __ ] etc
voilà on m'a menacé de me frapper on a
voulu me frapper
la production m'a enfermée à clef dans
une chambre
quoi oui c'était à moi alors lorsque
j'ai été agressé en fait là croyable le
problème ouais c'est que j'ai été j'ai
été agressé par deux candidats
physiquement ce ne sont pas ces
candidats qui ont été sanctionnés non
c'est moi qui l'a été c'est moi qui a
été mise à part alors que j'ai subi une
agression et on m'a enfermée dans une
pièce c'est quoi la clé cinq semaines
pour nos téléspectateurs dont vous êtes
dans une émission vous subissez
l'agression qu'est ce qui s'est passé
l'agression en question oui alors à
chaque fois sa part toujours de deux
fins de raisons qui n'ont aucun sens
c'est des trucs complètement débile
c'est les cdos les prétextes pour
s'acharner sur nous c'est n'importe quoi
ça qui donne mans qui donne ce cet ordre
de s'acharner sur une personne c'est
quoi dans ses marines et dans le
scénario à la ftq est subtilement c'est
à dire que c'est ces personnes là sont
encouragés par la production
donc en fait par exemple si il y à un
candidat qui je tiens à rappeler une
chose qui est primordial c'est que nous
sommes employés
la grosse équipe donc oui notre
employeur donc il y a les lois du
travail qui doivent être respectées et
par exemple vous sert il je prends un
exemple si vous surprenez un chroniqueur
en train de consommer la drogue sur son
lieu de travail vous sanctionner c'est
l'entourage et il sort il sort
directement si vous surprenez une
candidate
une chroniqueuse en train de tirer les
cheveux d'une eau chronicles vous l'a
sanctionné sinon c'est pas bien c'est
bien ça veut dire que c'est
et ces voix là mais manninger voilà qui
je vais vous dire je sais ce que voulait
dire c'est que la production privilégie
le casting existeront peut pas se passer
de ces personnes et qu'il ya des gens
qui font ce qu'ils veulent
dans cette production c'est ça ce que
voulait dire exactement exception c'est
à dire qu'en fait lorsque ces candidats
donc commettre des actes illégaux ils
sont encouragés mais c'est vachement
bien ce que tu fais c'est génial
continues tu es trop fort je vais vous
donner un exemple il ya il ya une année
une candidate qui un candidat a balancé
deux sauts de javel au visage non oui et
il y là il était sur le point lui
balancer un sceau du rin pour faire
plaisir à son patron pour aller plus
loin et finalement un caméraman lui
arracher ce sont des mains parce que je
pense que l'humain a pris a pris le
dessus sur la production n'a pas fait
vous avez des infos à paris voici
l'interview team en ce que vous racontez
c'est du harcèlement moral qui est un
délit et d'après mes informations vous
songé à aller en justice a porté plainte
tout voilà et il ya une autre forme de
menaces qu'ils aient l'obligation au
sein de la production notamment par
certaines productrice de vous mettre en
couple et si vous ne vous mettez pas en
couple vous êtes viré